[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants font que j'espère
que vous avez été sages j'espère tous
vous refusez tout ça est ce que nounours
a été sage jusqu'au où vous m'avez bien
du poteau gros copains de nounours
descend vite voir nicolas et pimprenelle
au lieu de faire le perroquet jus fonde
pas trop où l'eau
j'oubliais mon le choc du chaos j'étais
ben oui mais tu en as trop manger des
bonbons dernier nicholas au soir le zoo
alors le hollow
que se passe outre il est à moins de
douze énervant surtout pas du talent on
va le tirer au sort oui mais
on ne touche pas attention venez à côté
de moi
là nous allons jouer les joueurs vont se
sauver il y en a un qui va rester qui va
essayer de les attraper
ce sera trois là là celle ou celui que
daisy ma volonté ou mon signe je le
montre avec le doigt
ce sera toi nous attendent et ne nous
énervons pas nous recommence et c'est
moi qui compte
nous allons les jouer à fond ce
championnat a que ça qui va essayer de
les attraper
c'est sur un crâne à celle ou celui
cadets juniors ma volonté m en chine
je le montre avec le doigt ce sera toi
bravo il est pour moi ce petit pompon
mais j'ai une surprise pour les enfants
qui vont vite au lit
[Musique]
montpon
c'est moi qui ai gagné nous c'est pas
vrai nicolas je me suis couché en même
temps que toi du bien c'est parfait
vous avez gagné tous les deux une belle
6 heures sinon est ce que tu es gentil
rinne pour nicolas et l'une pour pas
preneur walt nord mais voulait mangerez
demain d'accord j'oubliais une sucette
aussi pour doudou une grosse
et voilà jettent à la lueur boonen une
icône a fait preuve que prône m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit les enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents il a tu vois là
nounours - beaucoup beaucoup plus
vraiment tu es trop gourmand où tu vas
te rendre malade se colle mon bon pas
trop
pour les susurre du coup non merci
allons en route nounours bonne nuit à
demain hu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]